this video was inspired by this quran
verse in surah maidah
verse 8. allah says
all you who believe be steadfast in the
cause of allah
bearing witness in equity and let not a
people's enmity
inside you to act unjustly be always
just
that is nearer to righteousness and fear
allah surely allah is aware of what you
do
salaam alaikum brothers and sisters in
dear friends
this is a unique kind of video that i'll
be doing the reason it's a special video
it's because it requires as muslims
and duat or people in a apologetic scene
muslim apology apologetic scene
if we really follow the sunnah of the
prophet peace be upon him we really need
to say you know what hold on a second
there is sometimes things that require
for us to do which the religion teaches
us
the quran teaches us allah's messenger
teaches us
and how he dealt with people that hated
him
yeah yes he was a person who was a
salah also a military man yes of course
when times needed
and he saw a threat to his companions he
did what is right and how
people twist this but mainly he was
forgiven and he wanted the best
for the people and we want to learn a
lesson from that because he was a mercy
to mankind
yeah and because of that roman sisters
that allah
tells us in the quran that repel
evil with what is best
and today we're going to be putting that
verse into action
we are going to look at the prophet
salallahu's life
and have mercy to such people like david
because the hatred inside him has burned
him as has enraged him to such a level
that he has made this an absolute living
and i didn't know that this guy actually
lives off this
i thought he might have a part-time job
like me personally i do uber you know i
try my best not to rely on this
you know it's not good for the soul you
know but it seems like david wood
is doing everything but that he is this
is his soul
bread and butter and he is feeding his
kids
his two innocent disabled kids
with this very hate but
his kids are free from the father we're
gonna watch a video i'm to react to this
video
because david wood's youtube channel has
been demonetized and it seems like that
has
really really got to him and we're going
to learn some lessons
and also we're going to do something
special insha'allah for the sake of
subhanallah yes we're going to do this
for the sake of surprise
now would david allow us to do it that
is this question
and we're going to wait for him to reply
to us let's not waste any time and get
straight to the video
now to everyone else especially to
people who were channel members and
people who contributed super chats
fortunately i have a bunch of supporters
on patreon already so this isn't a
situation where
demonetization by youtube could cause my
kids to starve
although that seems like the goal of he
actually feeds his kids
with hate mongering and hate preaching
also my wife and i realized that we need
to finally install a wheelchair lift in
our van we've been using a ramp for the
past three years
but as our two disabled sons have gotten
bigger the ramp isn't working out as
well
my wife accidentally started going over
the edge of the ramp last month with my
son paley
no injuries we caught the wheelchair and
got haley back up on the ramp
but we need a lift installed and the
estimate i got was roughly eight times
higher
than i thought it would be so losing
income right now doesn't help
but we can always do a gofundme for
something like that
you know what david your kids are
innocent to this matter
eight times the price no problem we as
the muslim community
and i'm sure non-muslims will be given
as well we are ready
yes you heard it right we as the muslim
community
are ready to raise eight times the
amount
yes inshallah with the permission of god
almighty i know i know who's gonna be
watching this and be like
what brother ali what this filthy
liar this person who insults the prophet
ripped the quran
you want to raise funds for his kids
yes because the quran
and the sunnah tells us to how broken
sisters when given in sadaqah
yeah we are not told is that yes okay
has a portion to the muslims like the
poor yeah the poor people yeah
we are allowed to give and we are going
to give
if you follow the quran and the sunnah
genuinely yes
you will give inshallah brothers and
sisters that is the reason we're going
to do it and i urge
every single people to do you know why
because these kids are innocent
their dad is a hate-filled preacher who
does nothing but lies
and because we muslims criticize
christianity criticize not insult we
don't insult
the trinity we don't insult jesus peace
be upon him we don't insult
we criticize and say this doesn't make
sense and because they are hurt by that
and because
they can't answer these questions what
do they do instead they think
we know will attack islam and light and
mock that's not the two same things
so please get that right so guys because
of that eight times the amount
here's the conditions we will do a
gofundme
just a quick disclaimer i know very well
he's going to be saying i'm not going to
accept no money from jihadis
well guess what um it's not from us we
know you're going to be using that
excuse it's from the muslim community
we're just setting up the gold fund me
and what we give privately that's on our
account
that's gonna have to do that's between
us and our lord but it's the muslim
community
your gofundme because we don't know if
you're gonna use the money there give us
the exact amount or we can
you choose you choose we are going to
nominate we're gonna find somebody a
muslim
near your area or you know actually no
no you know what you're going to
probably think you know
is to set up they're going to try to
kill me kind of nonsense yeah
no problem yeah however comfortable we
can get a muslim
he would have the funds he will go with
you or wherever that to get it or
we will go and buy it we will transfer
the funds to the company
and you will go and pick it up that's a
deal
i am looking for you to contact me and
we would like to go ahead and set up a
gofundme
tell us how much it is and we are going
to do this because we don't believe
the amount of money you make on youtube
it's probably ten thousand dollars or
more plus a month
yeah and we don't believe in your lies
um uh
that you know it's it's impacted you in
that context ten thousand dollars i
don't know what kind of lavish life you
need to live
however we acknowledge that you have
disabled kids and we
are going to inshallah with the
permission of god first we want to ask
you to get a real job
please get a real job and earn a proper
living yeah instead of begging
spreading hate and we are going to fund
inshallah
totally or a part of that so
the call is yours you want to accept you
don't want to accept that is up to you
yeah you want to twist this do whatever
you like we as the muslim community
and i'm telling you everyone be on board
for your kids if they need that lift
we are ready to purchase it we're ready
to purchase it
please get in contact with me um your
team members whoever it may be
this is done for the sake of allah for
your kids
yeah okay because as muslims we believe
in sadakira anything that we do good to
anybody
we get benefits in the hereafter so as
your kids use this lift hopefully it'll
be a reward for us
and hopefully it can make ease them and
has this one happen
uh of them falling and you claim your
income is hurt no problem
we are happy that your income is not
because your kids are gonna suffer no no
no
we are happy because this is your source
of income to spread hate and lies
but for your kids no problem we as a
muslim community will come together
so guys that's about from video
inshallah and
um whoever's watching this guys once we
start the fundraiser inshallah
if they firstly allow us if he doesn't
allow us
it says a lot about himself um and we're
going to see inshallah we are ready and
happy and willingly
willingly want to do this good deed for
his kids
his kids are innocent brothers and
sisters and may allah deal with this
person or may allah guide him
please share this video wide inshallah
and like we said before
this is a powerful religion brahmana
sisters sometimes to have
mercy rather than hatred till next time
alaikum
and get some sleep